triple parity shoe Ball State log jammer
to baggage cling
Aaron Rodgers
cow
[Applause]
hi everybody I'm Dave stasis alongside
Jeff Worthington and welcome to the
annual East West Bowl as we get ready to
watch some of the best college players
in the nation showcase their skills in a
classic showdown between east and west
and there really are some characters on
this year's squads Arthur Jeff that's
right Dave it does seem like the most
flamboyant personalities came to the
Forefront and they are here let's meet
the players from the East
[Music]
Demarcus Williams University of Georgia
T.J Jackson Wayne State University
Tavarius Miss King Merrimack College
Carl Royals smoochie Wallace University
Miami the squarius green Junior
University of Notre Dame Ibrahim Moore
Zeus University of Tennessee at
Chattanooga Jack Marius attack theratrix
Michigan State University the Isaiah T
buildings Club Coastal Carolina
University the Jeff for probing Crux III
South Carolina State University
Leos Maxwell Jr East Carolina University
Javaris Jamar jamaris and Lamar
University of Middle Tennessee devoine
shower handle
University of Southern Mississippi
Penn State University
Le carpetron Duke Marriott
Florida Atlantic University the Dinklage
Morgan
University of South Florida
Xmas Jackson flexing waxing California
University of Pennsylvania
[Music]
we're going to be looking for big plays
all game long from tyrol Smoochy Wallace
and let's not forget the tight ends
Ibraham moisus and hengel mccringleberry
they've both had amazing season that's
right Jeff now let's meet the players
from the West
[Music]
vegetarian Jefferson
Texas A M
um the cluster her Duncan Church
University Wisconsin swarvathon L good
inks flat
Saskatchewan University quattroville
Quattro San Jose State University
awesome attacks buckshank
Stanford University these are 12 washing
beers
Jones college
TGIF Carter University of Northern
Arizona X Wayne at aliciousness Missouri
Western State University sequester
grundle plit MD Adam State scores
Velociraptor malloy's South Dakota State
University TJ AJ RJ backslashes fourth
the fifth Albion College
San Diego State University donkey teeth
Boise State University torque
Louis
Nevada state
Penitentiary the player formerly known
as Mouse cop
University of Missouri Columbia Dan
Smith BYU
[Music]
I'm Dave stassen alongside Jeff Worthing
and welcome to the 2013 East West poll
where we're going to be watching some of
the best college athletes in the nation
try to put last year's spectacle to
shame that's right Dave it won't be easy
but this year's seniors certainly will
be trying to give last year's Stars a
run for their money let's check out the
team starting with the players from the
East
[Music]
cause Nestor Smith Ruckus University
ellipses quarter University of Alabama
now aquilis Dale why LSU bismo Funyuns
Florida State University
Margaret Troy Seattle University of
Louisville Chris and The Time Fitness
University of Tennessee
Ole Miss crocodile blimp Auburn
University Julius boosler
the you Muscatine Tristan University of
Michigan fall Trail plugins University
of Arkansas
cartoons plural Virginia Tech Jammy
Jammy Jammy V Ohio State University
food
some of the big stories this year the
meteoric rise of the Pez poopsie and
let's not forget about Heisman winner
Jammy Jammy Jammy and remember you can't
talk about 2013 without bringing up
fudge everybody's talking about fudge at
350 pounds this running back is almost
Unstoppable the whole year you're right
I could talk about fudge all day but
first let's meet the players from the
West
[Music]
equine ducklings Indiana University
Purdue University Indianapolis Daw
historius La mistorius Utah State
University
Oklahoma State University Exquisite team
bubbleish Winslow University of Nebraska
hookah lakanaka hakanakahika hakafaka
University of Hawaii King Prince
chambermaid
Baylor University
of Colorado
University of Arizona Harvard University
DeVry University
beep
Army
Navy Surplus Store Wing Days
online classes first name last name
College University God
homeschool squeeze
Santa Monica College Benedict's
Cumberbatch
Oxford University A.A Ron bolake
Morehouse College
welcome to the 2015 East West Bowl pro
edition of all the All-Star games and
professional sports this one is sure to
be the most extravagant that's right
these players were selected by the fans
too and when it comes to Flair these
characters are the creme de La Creme
[Music]
creme de La Creme
Cosgrove Shumway
Clemson HaHa Clinton-Dix University of
Alabama
Marshall legume Dupree West Virginia
University
of Central Florida
senior Central Connecticut State
University
Southern University the birkenshaw
Ferguson University of Virginia from
Florida
University of South Carolina still
Tavian roboclick
Grambling State Cornelius Tank Carradine
Florida State University
vergonia's Thicket suede Duke mama Dune
shazbot
Tulane University swordless mime town
Jacksonville State University
there is a lot of talent in this in this
game Eric let me tell you something when
you look at Players like marmadoon
shazbot HaHa Clinton-Dix and strong plug
it you're looking at players who made an
impact this year I mean is HaHa
Clinton-Dix even real this guy was
amazing so solid all season long for the
Green Bay Packers and when you throw in
guys like Lagoon Dupree worthless mime
Town into brickashaw Ferguson this is
surely going to be a squad for the ages
I agree now let's meet the players from
the West
Prince of mukamera University of
Nebraska
Junior juniors
Junior
Texas Christian University oh Dallas
University Oregon
Fozzie Whittaker the University of Texas
myriad
profiteroles
Utah
Busters Brown
Illinois cupcake
man
you know herself
it's a small kitchen Kent State
University take it to them
limit
College of the Canyons
snarf men's plots East Los Angeles
College Frosty Rucker University of
Southern California
triple parakeet shoe Ball State log
jammer to baggage cling
North Texas University
Aaron Rodgers Cal
EB
[Music]